this episode is brought to you by
t-mobile now Netflix has included
another reason why t-mobile is America's
best unlimited network switch today
hello screen junkies it's time to watch
the honest trailer for 2017 s the month
1616 yes oh my god again ignore and I'm
here with Spencer Gilbert dan Morel I
hated this movie I hated this movie I
left this movie so and I remember having
I pity this movie yeah I hate it even
more after I saw and I've hated it ever
since and I couldn't I couldn't bear re
watching this one because I was like no
I'm not I can't put my brain through it
again this was just the most lazy
pitiful pointless nonsensical mess of a
movie that I feel like I've seen in a
long time like at least transformers has
transformers doing transformer things
yeah there wasn't even a mummy in this
this is I mean I think you wrote the
line Spencer this is exact this is a
group this is a collection of studio
nuts masquerading as a movie exactly
like that you could tell they were just
like at some point they wanted to remake
the mummy and then it got so wrapped up
in the dark universe I remember when we
went to the screening of this when the
universal logo turned to dark universe
at the beginning of every month I went
oh no
there was a groan yeah there was there's
losing like oh boy and this just turned
into that same it wouldn't be as bad if
it hadn't failed so many times before
the whole universe building and the
first movie thing I know this is gonna
sound dumb but it wouldn't be as bad if
it was better because you could do a
movie that I think you could do a
standalone movie that also sprinkles in
a hint of a larger world yeah I agree
but the seams were so visible the movie
would stop they'd be like here's the
next one that's coming out well and then
it would start again and then it would
stop and be like this is gonna be in the
next one it was not only that but it was
I just I've never been talked down to in
a movie and the last time I remember
where they literally would tell you her
origin over and OH
flashing back to the back in the
beginning and you're like I get it just
do cool [ __ ] I don't see the story it
was a voiceover
over-explaining ah for the dumbest
easiest plot to remember it once revenge
this [ __ ] like she's a mummy yeah okay
they could not even go on an adventure
it was like what is Tom Cruise what's
his profession is he an archaeologist
but he does know what secret young man I
poor Sophie would tell she really got
the shortest sheet rides like resurrect
the mummy only to immediately chain her
up again and then she has one apocalypse
scene with the sand bugs which could
control minds we make sure all the winds
I can make the winds I just kill them
all like I understand what took her so
long and she didn't yeah most other
interesting thing to me this movie was
like the aftermath and they try to like
instill the blame and then there was a
whole like hits piece on Tom Cruise
really directed the movie like he took
over and it was all his idea it's like
wow but apparently I read that and then
his idea was to make him into the bad
guy which was like there's a kernel of
something interesting I there just like
there's a kernel of something
interesting and making a new mommy movie
but no they just know I write it was so
much trouble near gabions I've just
mushed up in one of them car chase I'm
running through the streets just mash it
around like a cook just bacon oh this is
sexy McDonald's burger but it's just
this idea just like people aren't gonna
get this as a shared universe unless we
establish everything right off the bat
and it's like first of all this or a
storytelling point that's not true
secondly that's demonstrable not true
like it's literally not true Marvel it
did it they didn't they did
I ain't mean to fail because of this
yeah an amazing spider-man dimensions
failed because of this and the universe
is like but I can do it you can't you
want yeah the other thing that's so
weird it because I will get to the
trailer well why mr. Hyde chosen but
what like let's go back to the old
school Universal monster movies they
were never there best when they were
fighting together like that was never
what those movies were about that was
Simon and Costello words exactly or the
monster squad but it's like those were
jokey more lego movie type things then
yeah then I'm not like oh I can't wait
for Frankenstein and Dracula in the
Wolfman that's when it got cheesy and
stupid that's the fundamental
misunderstanding I think the universal
had which is ironic because it's they're
monsters yeah they didn't do
Frankenstein battles Dracula until they
deform the creatively bankrupt super
people needed to get fired for this one
this was just like the most asinine
pointless idea and it's just yeah I
don't I don't get how is a Kurtzman or
Alex Kurtzman I look I don't know the
guy I don't mean to play I just from the
optics of how it is as a consumer it
just seems like someone's got to wise up
to this guy well whatever the studio
wants and it's not his fault but man
it's now there's a transformer spider in
this from just yeah you cannot you
should not be in charge of a franchise
done that well ya know it may be I feel
like this these are all studio movies
and I get it and plus when you get Tom
Cruise on board and now Tom Cruise
brings his Tom Cruise inist to it and
like there's certain things that Tom
Cruise has to do he didn't fit this
character at all the character was not
supposed to unlikable and he was
supposed to be way younger and he was
Tom Cruise and he was always like well
cuz he's Tom Cruise people like him it
hasn't that likable in this but that's
the thing but he but like they kept
telling you he his character wasn't
likable but it's doing unlikely things
but the way he was playing it was
rubbish Tom Cruise charm it's like but
you're supposed to actually hate the guy
but you don't because Tom Cruise doesn't
really do that that's not what he does
if he's playing a bad guys which would
never sing exactly as he played like
kind of a
well he was a great bad guy so he can do
it it's just that there was a disconnect
just hodgepodge of moving pieces that
did not connect and I agree I am a Tom
Cruise action movie fan I'm a Tom Cruise
movie fan I think he's a movie star he
brings that charisma on he knows how to
make a big-budget movie the mission
impossible franchise he's kept that
going through exciting directors and
things this just I think the idea was as
shallow as like you can be the Robert
Downey jr. of the dark universe so be
like a funny [ __ ] and he was just
trying to do that he's even drinking
he's even got a drinking problem in the
movie Wow
never even considered that might be
who's gonna be spoiler alert he's just
then the weird ghost man the dagger with
the jewel in it which means that the
spirit of sets that came into him so now
he's a battling devil inside I'm
[ __ ] me I'm curious your if you're
watching this there has to be people out
there who enjoyed there a lot of people
out there just that was like they're
like the how do you do it how did you do
like the action how did you turn off
your brain and not get so consumed with
the idiocy idiocracy like the stupid
[ __ ] of this I want to know I'm not
trying to judge you or be mean to you
like like be telling be honest don't say
I'm an idiot cuz I know but what was is
about this film because you just turned
your brain off you could join them yes I
was you're gonna get a lot of it was on
the mummy the original trilogy with
Branagh Fraser yeah but that was fun
that was fun though I was not a great
movie but it was a fun adventure romp
but you know fun things that happened I
would argue that that's a very good
movie actually it's I think it's words
drawn in the first one I would say it's
actually a pretty angry watched it
that's not a bad movie it's really not
it's like you know be let be leveraged
it's a great movie I understand it's a
great movie
but it's gonna be bad fun I can't be fun
I would say that it's a really fun but
not drastic world it's not just
so really it's got a lot of fun in it
but especially not a bad move he's got
some good humor and I got some good
jokes looks great well shot not that
kind of bland brightness that every
movie has nowadays when they want to go
for the effects thing where everything's
just lit bright so that you can do cheap
effects mm that's a whole other issue I
have but ya know I like the the Brendan
Fraser mummy way more than this
well should we watch it yeah I feel like
we have it justice bar there but let's
let's try and see video starts now video
starts what is dead may rise again and
the past cannot stay buried for long
so when universal needed a cinematic
universe they dug up the rotting end is
even - what's that Frankenstein that
likes the fun of the Brendan Fraser
version missus the horror of the
original and settles into its own stale
blood of action blockbuster cliches that
manage to kill all hype for the dark
universe before it even began because
when you want to murder a franchise by
cramming it full of spin off bait you
get the guy who did the exact same thing
to spider-man
how about Kurtzman uses his powers for
good and writes a Transformers movie
again there's a lot of people involved
maybe but his name keeps showing up like
a like a serial killers calling card do
you think there was this the moment when
he was shooting that scene of Tom Cruise
walking through Prodigy I'm looking at
everything behind glass of all the
vampire skulls and you know and he's
just like
[Music]
you think you'd learn you think so
that's why he meant or see ya get back
with no yeah there's a hole don't know
what the difference is to be honest go
look that's another video yeah alright
keep going
oh he did twice the bummy is back and
she's all hot now complete with sexy
henna tattoos strategist pg-13 money
please Howard just sexy bandages she's
back to take revenge on the world I've
gotta say making a deal with the devil a
deal they gave her the power to kill two
sleeping people and a baby huh not sure
you had to bring the devil into that
what did the god of death give her
except the tattoos and a knife tattoo
and a knife yeah she did just win at
fairs he's made her murder she wanted to
be fair because she had a male child so
he jumped her in succession she just
murdered those people that are doing the
deal with the devil pull yeah that's a
good point
anyways I just felt like we says that no
it's not like you know armor vas you
know he had a kid that I don't know
that's motivation that killed his lover
he's gonna find her and that's what's in
the moon right so and he was mummified
against his will
yeah well she was - yes she was are evil
that's the thing we're giving us way too
much thought all right let's go ahead to
bring the devil into that and the only
way to stop her is to resurrect the god
of death by pairing the magic dagger
with a super jab then kill the host
before the ritual is complete and like
this is exactly why people don't go to
lunch anymore for no reason like we
found the gem but not the dagger we need
to you light it in the
to for a few minutes I'm thin journey
kind of like the thing to find this way
to brush it there and meet Nick Morton a
younger man of such for you man Tom
Cruise like should I fix this line Oh
Mike call out Tom Cruise and that say
he's not a record Tom Cruise a year
older than Russell Crowe I told Melissa
mom I noticed there's a line in the
script here it says I call you a young
man I was like with that Tom Cruise like
yeah Russell Crowe and Tom Cruise have
covered the conversation between them
that would be fascinating let's keep
fighting them charming
watch him bumble from action scene to
exposition job without pausing to
develop his character beyond
homeschooled Indiana Jones or writing
Sindelar never disrespectful I'm not
interested in archaeological tickety's
he knows what hieroglyphics are he's the
worst grave robber ever that's true cos
he getting the grave and all he gets
excited about his gold yeah oh the ghost
money I'm gonna make there's easier ways
to get [ __ ] rob a pharaoh he is
listed in the army to run fake recon
missions to find dig sites and say well
I'm trying to getting many soldiers
killed because he wasn't actually doing
any recon dodging not Isis and to find
goals it's at that point it would be
easier to be a robber yeah yeah just
some money from their houses
and less dangerous much less dangerous
we're gonna run into a war zone and
enter tombs that I know nothing about my
grandmother what I recollected glopitt
love it knowing meanwhile that if you
get caught you're gonna go to
Leavenworth for far longer than you
would go to high school president if you
got caught robbing somebody or boarded
toward rare election of duty
Stolen Valor like reason yeah sure
going enter the army and rise through
the ranks until you can stoom
archeological chart in this rare
crucified champion that plays a gig his
greatest strength as an actor if
everyone becomes a straight run
sorry broski Tom's got a ride it's in
his contract right next to the Hank from
something clause sit through this loose
collection of studio nose masquerading
is a single movie that somehow manages
to talk down to you what are we even
doing with one unholy purpose holding it
all together make the dark universe
happen every plans this fancy but a
mummy stops dead in its tracks own
version of Nick Fury
my name is Jekyll dr. Henry Jekyll its
own version of shield
welcome to prediction and it's very own
Hollis has been oz oh hey I spied the
creature from the black with guns arm
over there my grandpa would have been so
excited he were still alive
Missy papa so if the prospect of an
action movie universe starring guys in
their fifties fighting monsters from the
30s excites you saddle up for the first
and potentially last time you'll get to
see it before Universal gets the crazy
idea to and I know this is nuts but just
hear me out actually do something scary
and original with a horror movie get out
starring
and enf owns it in an American ripoff in
London
sometimes the MD monsters find in
monsters fighting around the world a
waste of a perfectly good Courtney be
back this is a driller night a swarm of
spiders
how many swarm of rats a swarm of
terrible reviews and Brendan Fraser oh
how it would have been to throw the guy
cameo
where is he these days pause explanation
from Kurtzman was leik but it was like a
different time era like it wouldn't make
sense like we definitely bend over
backwards to come in like just make him
an extra I'm not saying cryogenically
unfreeze his character as a mummy
where's person it doesn't need to be
something all bedazzled it can just be
something like or bedeviled just crash
something together toss a salad with
scrambled eggs wrong creature yeah
that's Fraser Fraser maybe he's like at
a school ties to the
yeah boy haze Tom Cruise runs from sand
featuring The Mummy this movie was so
rushed they accidentally posted a man
with optimism which an insane xt posted
that trailer online that only had this
only so watch the whole thing it's just
silent and then it's like what's that
and then silence and then cool let's
just try it but there's no other sound
layers in there now whatever definitely
select file to upload lay versioning for
every driver gets a four cylinder the
other fine was you did there was some
channels turned off and no one called it
did it happen later did the version show
up with the actual Sun oh yeah yeah no
that's the IMAX trailer of the movie
this the first version that they posted
was that so a they export it as a
project or export to be the QC person
didn't catch it see the social media
person didn't care we've got a
university Justin yeah they took it down
and adjusted is you know what you post
forever and you can't take you back it
was an iMac staffer I'm so glad I didn't
waste IMAX money watching this movie
no more upset but yeah so yeah The Mummy
awful not not great
yes we think dark universe will return I
don't know one more I think is gonna
write a fragrant friend by Bill Condon I
think it's all I can't even really cast
it yet I don't think it's like I think
someone's on board what's his name the
big guy you know camera gosh took the
photo so now it's got a happening Tatum
and guess
x-men holding the stem I come back now
that Deadpool's working yeah maybe yeah
yeah this was a sweet about takes a
quickly ahead alts lots of starring oats
baked the dark universe happen because
if there's one thing other Studios
learned from Marvel it's that the
Avengers made money so go to an Avengers
as fast as possible starring top run the
Manny Tom on cruise control
yeah the incredible bulk monster bash
she's are a lot of alt titles we
couldn't figure out which one we wanted
to go doctor Tom Cruise set up
Frankenstein hate during the movie ride
a Frankenstein dr. Jekyll and mr. cruise
and also the mummy and some variations
on the look it's Tom Cruise sucking the
mummy so hard that it dies what a
perfect medicine eyes dark universe
poetic poetry look at that they both
suck so hard they die oh man what have
we not said we sort of said it all look
we did this so you don't have to I don't
need to watch this one it and this one's
this one's not like a dumb fun one to
watch later let go check it out I don't
know I I implore if you have our a fan
of this film please go in the comments
and let's have a respectful exchange cuz
argue it's marriage work here tell me or
merit why did you enjoy us and be honest
about it if you really loves it I'm
curious cuz I'm just trying to figure
out how this it went out for three he
wrote before with Joe who's out of time
right now not like it you did not like
it roughly over six billion which is not
a whole lot yeah I don't think anyone's
happy with this return it'll be
interesting if they try and bring it
back if they did how do you bring back
ghosts mummy Tom Sandman like how do you
explain that the next movie sandstorm
following him under his control at the
end yeah I don't how do you explain them
I don't even know I saw the movie let
alone in part two oh it's looking psycho
Sam man's back we played is the end of
the movie where is his zombie friend who
he screamed back to life
back and he comes back to life and then
he's like thanks for bringing me back to
my where are we going and what I would
do is you know imagine temperatures
literally says adventure it was like
it's like it's my sense of adventure was
a sense of adventure boy that's it
credits the movie and there's nothing
left for him to do it ends with Tom
Cruise erecting his best friend
off-screen hey yells his doctor doctor
lady back to ladies reasons character in
the history of movies that exist to be
rescued by Tom Cruise and falls that was
funny
guys yeah and Tom Cruise but he is the
devil inside of him too and then Russell
comes like who knows which side is gonna
win out hi mama was where it also broke
down whereas like they tease it tease
the mr. Hyde and I was like oh wow good
restraint there Universal you didn't do
it I'm kind of curious I want to see
what Weslaco does with this and then
literally 15 minutes later delicate
syringe to change my mind I don't want
to see this I have to just one more bone
to think he does to turn himself from
mr. Hyde back into dr. Jekyll he's like
the most like delicate little he has to
preload like with fine motor skills for
different syringes and his gun while
he's not well he's turning into the Hulk
no reason why I could've been set up by
an assistant a whole bunch of
simple yeah the buttons easy to lock
everyone in the room that just takes a
ham fist to the button yeah of course
tell us what you think we'll be back
next week with another honest trailer
commentary here let's go check these
news I'm going this episode is brought
to you by t-mobile want to hear how
America's best unlimited that work is
upping their game now get Netflix
included with your family glad there's
never been a better time to switch